[Music]
hi
why hello there
we can tell i want to talk to her
well you should have called her pedro
i know i'm not gonna call her like i
can't show to my house anytime that one
no
pedro
why why do you not have your wife's
phone number because i believe that i
know can pay the cell phone plan and how
to move on to the cell phone plan
you can't pay the cell phone plan
but you had to move on yeah
have some respect go away now and call
call chantal on the phone okay it's only
coming here to tell them for real
they're going to get divorced from her
okay
she knows that already you are you've
already told her
yeah they're going to follow the
paperwork that's it
well
guess what that's no that's the normal
thing that happens when you get a
divorce
typically you have to file the paperwork
yeah okay and that's why she's gonna be
happy she never want to have depression
again
she wanna be happy because you know how
she said they made her like miserable
impossible all this stuff
tell her i never heard her say no no no
no no no or impossible no no
tell her that now she wants to have
everything she needs because she wants
to be happy
well i think you'll have everything that
you need because you asked for a divorce
so you're going to be happy oh and
you'll have the most fabulous divorce
ever and i mean ever
yeah yeah you asked for it so you're
gonna get it
okay
okay bye all right bye now
they're fake family
they're fake
monfe
all the fake
all the progress that i met with is now
was real
for me for me the program meant for him
for me was feel real
because there was the only family guy
over here to say there were
but in the end
i feel always very fake
[Music]
i feel that i never see until again this
moment
i go there to tell her you know what the
end of the story is and she don't want
to hear
[Music]